lors de notre second débat je vous
propose d'entrer dans la tête d'
emmanuel macron avec des biographes on
va tenter de cerner la psychologie le
style l'exercice du pouvoir celui que
l'on surnomme le maître des horloges qui
on va commencer par ça at il perdu le
tempo premier élément de réponse quand
un call me
emmanuel macron très actif pour l'heure
à l'international cherche à gagner du
temps sur la scène politique française
après le sommet européen de jeudi et
vendredi le président de la république
participe à la réunion du g7 aujourd'hui
et demain avant de s'envoler pour le
portugal mais ce week end au milieu de
cette séquence il a accordé une
interview à l' agence france-presse
première étape confirmé sa confiance à
elisabeth bornes et l'a chargé d'une
mission pour les prochains jours j'ai
donné mandat à elisabeth bornes de
formellement et précisément explorer
avec les groupes de l'assemblée
nationale qui correspondent à des forces
politiques de gouvernement le degré de
coopération auquel ils sont prêts il ya
bien effectivement en termes de
communication et de présentation par le
chef d'état de la situation l'idée de se
mettre un peu en hauteur au dessus de la
mêlée comme si lui apprenait acte d'une
situation certes qui n'a pas voulu mais
prenez acte d'une situation et demander
aux à la cheffe du gouvernement d'en
tirer des conclusions d'élaborer des
scénarios de faire des propositions et
le chef de l'état de citer plusieurs cas
de figure de l'union de gouvernement au
vote oka par quatre textes par texte et
là encore emmanuel macron dispose de
quelques atouts dans son jeu les cartes
sont déjà pour partie entre ses mains
puisqu'ils ont été séduits ils doivent
proposer puisque c'est lui qui a la main
sur la manière dont le gouvernement est
composé c'est lui qui nomme le premier
ministre et qui nomme les membres du
gouvernement en accord avec la première
où le premier ministre tout est à
inventer et c'est au président
tivité de pragmatisme et de réaliser
l'elysée annoncera le nouveau
gouvernement dans les prochains jours
début juillet après le retour du chef de
l'état à paris
allez on va faire un tour dans la tête
d' emmanuel macron en tout cas c'est la
promesse de se de ce débat vous présente
mes invités corinne lhaïk bonsoir
bienvenue vous êtes journalistes
politiques à l'opinion ou publié avec
eric m'en donnait la nuit tombe deux
fois c'est aux éditions fayard nicolas
domenach bonsoir bienvenue à vous aussi
vous êtes chroniqueur politique à
l'hebdomadaire challenges hauteur avec
maurice szafran de macron pourquoi tant
de haine publié aux éditions albin
michel j'accueille également jean
sébastien ferjou bonsoir bienvenue vous
êtes le directeur de la publication du
site atlantico et matthieu croissandeau
éditorialiste politique et restait
évidemment à mes côtés je commence par
la question convient d'aborder dans
notre sujet d'ouverture corinne lhaïk
mêmes macro un type toujours le le
maître des horloges clairement non
ça doit le faire un peut enrager
certains disent même qu'il a perdu la
main est ce qu'il pourra la retrouver
c'est une autre question mais il a réagi
dans cette crise comme il réagit
face à toutes les crises n'ont pas la
crise les crises qui sont adressés à
tous les gouvernements du monde comme
locaux vides ou l'ukraine pour l'europe
mais les crises qui sont franco
française est où il a une part de
responsabilité
je pense au gilet jaune et je pense à
cette crise première première réaction
état de choc de sidération
il est sonné parce que ses analyses
politiques ont été déjouées par la
réalité parce qu'il est battu et qu'il a
un problème politique à résoudre parce
que ses compagnons de route c'est
important quand même richard ferrand
christophe castaner ne sont plus à ses
côtés et on a beau dire que mâcon n'est
pas un affectif il tient beaucoup à ses
grognards à leur présence est donc ils
se trouvent face à une nouvelle donne il
a une première tendance à réagir par le
déni et puis après ils passent à la
phase de réflexion
maturation ça prend du temps et jusqu'à
présent le fait de prendre du temps et
de l'imposer aux autres lui avait plutôt
bien réussi en cela on pouvait
effectivement dire comme vous disiez
qu'il était le maître des horloges mais
cette fois ci ça ne lui a pas réussi
d'abord par exemple pendant la campagne
législative où il a mis beaucoup de
temps avant de nommer elizabeth bornes
après une fois qu'elle a été nommée il a
mis beaucoup de temps à l'art confirmée
alors qu'elle était quand même sur un
siège éjectable très contesté et puis
après il décide enfin de remonter sur
son cheval il intervient et là il donne
sa vision des choses et sa vision des
choses c'est toujours de ramener à ce
qu'ils pensent être le fils de son
quinquennat là il l'a fait en disant
attention j'ai été élu le 24 avril avec
un programme il a rappelé ce programme
et il a même remis la réforme des
retraites à l'ordre du jour donc il veut
rester sur son axe et il n'entend pas
être déstabilisés par ce qu'il se passe
à l'extérieur même si tu es facto
évidemment il l'est mais il fait tout
pour le cacher et pour feindre
d'organiser des événements qui ne
maîtrisent pas russe est intéressant
nicolas domenach parce que toujours sur
cette question de temporalité là il est
parti de nouveau une séquence
internationale mais il donne une feuille
de route est lésé des demandes qui qui
qui qui est datée et coire en dix ans
ici à la fin de la semaine il faut il
faut avoir trouvé une solution et puis
ensuite proposé un gouvernement dont qui
il fins et je reprends un peu
l'expression de collecte de rester le
maître des horloges est-ce que vous la
maca en tout cas ils s'y essaye et il
tente peixe une petite qu'un complément
sens que lui quand une quêté sus mais je
je je devrais peut-être l'assèchement ou
la dévitalisation d'avant veux dire
c'est pas le les législatives qui ont
été seulement le choc il est arrivé veut
dire quand même l'image du champ-de-mars
elle résumait touffu dire c'était un
moment qui n'avait si on reporte à la
palais royal la fois il avait en 2007 où
il était porteur d'une espérance du d'un
projet d'un dessin et ils n'étaient
porteurs de rien du tout vous dire il
est arrivé il a vaincu mais il n'a pas
convaincu et pour cause il n'avait pas
de dessin il n'avait pas de ils
n'étaient pas portés par quelque chose
de plus grand que lui il avait on avait
l'impression et comme la cinquième au
fond quand on gagne et c'est un rêve
c'est fait pour l'alternance c'est fait
pour porter quand vous alternez mais si
vous êtes ray là ça fonctionne plus de
la même façon je dirais donc il a il
était au fond un peu perdu et on a
l'impression qu'il n'a jamais retrouvé
quelque chose qui l'anima et que au fond
il était parti sur un avec alexis colère
qui est l'autre son autre lui-même dire
il était parti se réaliser cet ancien de
l'élite était parti sur un mouvement qui
n'en était pas un véritablement et donc
il s'est retrouvé un pad est ce qu'on
vit aujourd'hui c'est une de fonds ils
essayent de remettre la mécanique en
route jean sébastien ferjou est-ce que
alors si je vous entends je fais la
synthèse de vos de démonstration est ce
qu'il est sonné au soir de sa victoire à
la présidentielle finalement et belle
macro je crois qu'il ya une forme de
dévitalisation comme le disait nicolas
domenach est antérieure effectivement à
la présidentielle mais qui remonte
probablement même très loin c'est un peu
comme si finalement et même à cran et et
son propre programme plus qu'il n'avait
un projet en soi donc forcément une fois
que vous êtes réélu pour la deuxième
fois qu'il n'y aura pas de troisième que
se passe-t-il à ce moment là et pourquoi
je vous dis ça parce que
incontestablement 2017 il a réussi à
susciter un espoir sur une espèce de
révolution mais dès qu'on gratte un peu
on se rendait bien compte que c'était
assez illusoire mm macro est le pur
produit des élites françaises c'est
vraiment mais alors avec le côté
peut-être jeunes audacieux sexy si on
veut mais le pur produit la
technostructure française et cette
espèce de saint simonisme qui consiste à
croire qu'il ya des solutions techniques
finalement et que la politique ne compte
pas tant que ça donc oui il y avait un
projet sur les mots effectivement qui a
séduit des gens sur l'autonomie sur
l'émancipation de l'individu mais très
vite on s'est rendu compte que ça
n'était pas ce qui guidait son action
concrètement son action complètement
elle est restée très très heureux de ce
que j'ai fait n'importe quel autre
énarque issu à peu près la même
génération que lui quant au maître des
horloges je crois pas qu'il ait jamais
été véritablement regarder beaucoup d
erreurs du premier quinquennat c'est en
réalité edouard philippe qui les lui a
fait commettre alors avec son
consentement mais que ce soit sur le
fait de faire les appels en même temps
que la réforme de liesse f les 80
km/heure d'introduire le systémique par
le paramétrique pardon dans le
systémique de la réforme des retraites
maintenir le premier tour des
municipales en confinement peut-être qui
duraient plus longtemps que ce qu'on
aurait eu besoin en réalité madame macro
est beaucoup moins jupiter qu'il n'y
paraît il a eu ce génie marketing sur
lui même mais qu'est ce que vraiment le
maquereau nice mais politiquement
natiez une très bonne question ces cinq
ans après 5
ses protégés le match nice et un
pragmatisme
assez en tout cas l'image qu'il a donnée
on est loin de l'idéologie alors oui au
début on voulait débloquer la france
libérer les énergies protéger les plus
faibles il y avait un petit côté si tous
les gars du monde se donner la main et
si tous les gens de bonne volonté était
là on prendrait toutes les bonnes idées
qui s'imposerait qu'on a jamais osé
faire il y avait une forme d' audace une
forme de courage et avec également une
esthétique c'est drôle parce que quand
nicolas faisait allusion c'est vrai à
7,7 ce soir d'une victoire 2017 c'était
quasiment 2006 code et on finit en 2022
avec les choristes en fallait rien côté
on a descendu trois étages en symbolique
en esthétique comme s'ils étaient allés
au bout lui mais oui c'est d'accès comme
c'est un pragmatisme d'abord personne ne
connaît ce que c'est que ma chronique à
comprendre à commencer par ses propres
troupes c'est une synthèse de lui voilà
ma chronique c'est très simple macro
nisme ces macro voilà tout
lui qu'il maîtrise et donc c'est un
handicap quand même beaucoup pour le
reste parce que on peut suggérer des
idées quand on a la majorité mais on
n'est pas sûr que ça plaise aux patrons
puisque c'est au final le patron qui
décide et sait pas comment parti
socialiste vous aviez espèce de deux
produits de synthèse congrès après
congrès qui sait que la doxa globalement
elle était connue c'est pas la même
chose même chez les républicains où le
gaullisme ça avait un sens ou où les
libéraux qui était venu lui-même
paiement savez ce qu'ils défendent et là
on sait pas très bien un coup face et le
fameux et en même temps et c'est vrai
que il est arrivé au soir de cette
présidentielle le temps qu'il met à
choisir un premier je veux bien croire
que les stratèges de l'elysée nous ont
expliqué que c'était en fait hyper fin
hyper calculé parce que ça retard dès le
début de la campagne législative on n'en
parlerait pas enfin bref ça a tout donné
exactement inverse mais quand même
mettre autant de temps frappé à autant
de portes essuyé autant de refus pour
trouver un locataire de matignon alors
que vous êtes déjà en poste que vous
savez soi disant ce que vous voulez
faire et vous n'êtes pas fichu de
trouver dans votre propre majorité
quelqu'un et ça se fait au final je
parle sous le contrôle de corinne au
dernier week-end où finalement c'est un
plan b qui l'emportent sur le plan à
parce que françois bayrou est bien
content jean ferrat non plus le problème
demain c'est qu'il n'a pas n'a pas
réalisé que ces élections étaient
presque des élections de midterm c'est à
dire c'étaient des réactions de
validation les français l'ont choisie
parce que faute de mieux ou parce qu'ils
avaient peur de marine le pen et il a
pensé à l'elysée pour la cérémonie
d'investiture le message était attention
ce n'est pas une réélection c'est une
élection et ça à mon avis est une erreur
parce qu'en réalité c'est une réélection
et les français ont validé pour la
présidentielle mais ils l'ont
lilian donner un petit coup sur la
figure pour les législatives en lui
disant on t'a réélu parce que on n'a pas
trouvé mieux
en revanche la politique que tu veux
mener on n'est pas d'accord et je peux
vous dire au sein de la majorité
actuellement certains estiment que la
retraite à 65 ans leur aurait fait
perdre 100 sièges de députés pour le
groupe renaissance il ya deux points qui
focalisent leurs rancoeurs c'est la
retraite à 65 ans et les événements du
stade de france qui considère qu'ils ont
faim sur un discours à l'envers a fait
avoir ils se sont mis à dos la gauche à
cause des violences policières la droite
à cause du désordre et l'extrême droite
à cause de la délinquance de banlieue
qui a déferlé sur le stade de france et
donc et là ils estiment qu'ils ont perdu
alors je sais pas ce que valent ces
estimations ils estiment qu'ils ont
perdu une trentaine de députés donc
c'est vrai que le fait pour emmanuel
macron de ne pas avoir pris je suis
d'accord avec vos analyses qui disent
que effectivement la présidentielle déjà
il commençait un peu à être dévitalisées
mais c'est vrai que il n'a pas pris
conscience peut-être de l'importance de
ce scrutin des législatives il à
raisonner par analogie avec ce qui s'est
passé en 2010 est où il a une majorité
dans la foulée alors que tout le monde
lui prédisait qu'il n'aurait pas parce
qu'il était tout neuf que personne ne
connaissent et qu'ils n'avaient pas
d'appareil qui n'avait pas d'argent etc
et il a il a réussi quand même avoir une
majorité et l'avancé que cela ça allait
se reproduisent et sans avoir analysé
que les circonstances qui ont permis aux
choses de se produire une première fois
n'étaient pas réunies aujourd'hui et
donc il a un peu en jambes et cette
campagne des législatives qui a été
polluée à la fois par ces non décision
par le positionnement assez astucieux
des autres acteurs comme mélenchon et
par la mauvaise gestion de certains
événements mais nicolas derrien qui a
quand même
alerte quand même eu un certain nombre
de proches qui ont élu lui dit au fur et
à mesure que cette campagne des
législatives avant ses attentions ne
surprenait pas sur le bon chemin quoi ya
pas une nombreuse verte de proches de
moins proches des journalistes y lire
nous quand on est allé le voir pour
faire notre notre enquête on pensait pas
au départ faire une enquête sur la haine
contre lui quand on a lâché le mot haine
d'entrée on y la panda passé 2h30 alors
il est rarement bref mais quand même il
n'avait sale travail est et veut dire si
nous a retenu autant de temps que ça
alors qu'on cogné à la porte pour des
rendez-vous qui venait c'est que il
était quand même interpellé il se passe
quelque chose dans ce pays qui m'échappe
pour autant il développait effectivement
la thèse que son idée serait réélu parce
que les autres étaient mauvais et que
mécaniquement ensuite il y aurait les
législatives donc la première partie de
l' hypothèse il
il gagne mais ensuite et ensuite j'ai
gagné ensuite se plante oui mais et
encore une fois je reprends la question
sur les alertes parce que là vous
revenez avant
entre entre le second tour de la
présidentielle est
comment dire tout a été atténuée et tout
fait quand même le fonctionnement c'est
alexis kohler et lui et ses accès alexis
colère qui verrouille tout jédir y
compris les alertes se dire c'était très
difficile alors il a ses sources proches
qui reçoit des dizaines de sms etc mais
à l'arrivée c'est alexis colère qui fixe
quand même la ligne qui décide que pour
être élu il faudra un programme et non
pas approcher disruptif contrairement à
tout ce qu'on lui disait tout autour
donc je pense que c'est en tout cas ça a
beaucoup joué cet isolement à
l'intérieur du château et puis pour en
avoir parlé à des députés
il avait quand même un côté magique pour
la vie tu devais tout plein de députés
qu'ils sont fainéants 2017 qui n'aurait
alors que jamais dû être réélu sans lui
donc il y avait un côté ben lui oui sur
le terrain il il en prenait plein la
figure parce qu on leur parlait que
retraite à 65 ans il avait rien là
défendre parce qu'ils n'avaient aucune
mesure en positif à donner à part un peu
de pouvoir d'achat et l'éducation qui
crispe et quand même une bonne partie de
l'opinion mais le reste c'est et
filandreux personne n'avait rien à dire
c'était quand il disait pardon pardon m
quand même le seul à avoir été réélu
hors cohabitation enfin bien sûr et 11
ans personne n'a encore dit j'ai bien
compris qu'il y avait il y avait c'est
un futur devient et certainement des
raisons était pas lié à la personnalité
c'est lui le patron il s'est a priori ce
qui fait il est magique il a réussi à se
faire élire ces personnes à se faire
réélire c'est le seul donc bon ben on va
attendre de voir mais il n'y a pas une
grande culture de la démocratie
ce qui était un mouvement horizontal
comme un des murs du lien soit 10 francs
mais cette verticalité et en plus ça ne
marche que dans un sens donc c'est
compliqué quand sébastien n'est pas une
grande mesure de l'analyse de ce qui
fait les succès et les échecs mais pas
forcément uniquement chez makro on
pourrait parler la classe politique au
sens large les républicains ont pas
analyser les raisons de la défaite de
valérie pécresse nice se sont mis
d'accord sur celle de françois fillon
pas plus d'ailleurs qui ne se sont mis
d'accord sur les raisons de l'échec de
nicolas sarkozy et c'est la même chose à
peu près à gauche on trouve des gens qui
sont persuadés exactement exactement
entre ceux qui pensaient que c'était
parce qu'il n'était pas assez à gauche
ou d'autres qui n'avaient pas été assez
déterminés donc ça n'est pas nouveau
mais incontestablement et même accro un
mal compris le sens premier de sa
première élection même s'il y avait eu
un mouvement d'espoir m'enfin rappelons
le dans un alignement de planètes sans
précédent malgré tout il y avait eu le
fameux livre de confidences de françois
hollande qui l'a empêché enfin bon je
vais pas vous refaire toute la jce tout
le monde là présent et là c'était la
même chose ils n'étaient pas les autres
et ils étaient finalement ce que tout le
monde a bien compris l'incarnation du
système français donc à nous sommes un
pays dans lesquels il ya encore plus de
gens qui ont des choses à perdre que de
gens qui n'ont plus rien à perdre on ne
va pas vers l'aventuré politique les
pays qui vont vers l' aventure politique
sont les pays vous avez au moins une
majorité d'électeurs qui n'ont plus rien
à perdre et donc il dit on va essayer
l'extrême droite on va essayer je sais
pas quoi n'importe quelle solution
populiste parce que nous n'avons plus
rien à perdre ça n'est pas le cas en
france quand on regarde les montants de
l'epargne ce n'est pas le cas en france
quand on regarde le montant des
transferts sociaux qui ont lieu chaque
année et donc le message il est même à
la présidentielle et aux législatives
c'est en quelque sorte le statu quo à
défaut d'autre solution politique
d'alternative réelle qui nous convaincre
nous préférons le statu quo seuil à ne
pas faire grand chose sauf que ça
emmanuel macron comme une analyse à
travers le prisme de son génie personnel
il ya un peu de temps dans le final on
tombe alors un le chef de l'état peut-il
chef différemment ici engagé plusieurs
fois avant sa réélection lors de son
discours d'investiture mais aussi
mercredi dernier devant les français à
20 heures nous devons collectivement
apprendre à gouverner et légiférer
différemment
bâtir avec les formations politiques
constituant la nouvelle assemblée des
compromis nouveau dans le dialogue
l'écouté le respect c'est ce que vous
avez souhaité et j'en prends acte cela
ne doit pas vouloir dire l'immobilisme
cela doit signifier des accords en
prenant le temps de les faire
par le dialogue le respect d'exigences
corinne lhaïk vous aviez publié une
biographie du prix en république en 2020
emmanuel macron président cambrioleurs
c'est le titre de ce livre également
publié chez fayard est ce qui peut
changer sa façon de gouverner est ce que
vous y croyez une seconde je pense qu'il
ne peut changer que sous la force d'une
contrainte extrême parce que par
tempérament il n'est pas très quatrième
république quand même hein il est
vraiment il a mis ses pieds dans les
chaussons de la vème république une
cinquième république qu'un peu
intégristes avec beaucoup d'aisance donc
depuis le début de son mandat enfin
depuis le après la première phase de son
mandat mais depuis la sphère des gilet
jaune ils n'arrêtent pas de dire qu'il
faut gouverner autrement il le fait avec
le grand débat il essaye de le faire
avec la convention citoyenne à chaque
fois en fait c'est quand même lui qu'il
remet au centre au centre du jeu et là
ils n'arrêtent pas de promettre une
nouvelle méthode
je doute qu'il y parvienne la nouvelle
méthode est lui un petit peu imposée par
la force des événements
qu'est ce qui va en sortir
peut-être qu'il va réussir pendant
quelques mois à maintenir elisabeth
porno gouvernement mais fondamentalement
j'ai de gros doutes sur sa capacité à
changer la méthode j'ai de gros doutes
sur la capacité des autres aussi accepté
ce changement de méthode parce que toute
la classe politique tous les
observateurs sont un peu drogués au fait
majoritaire tout le monde raisonne par
rapport à ça tu es avec moi où tu es
contre moi donc on est quand même dans
une période d'incertitude inédite et
je pense qu emmanuel macron ne serait ce
que par la manière dont il s'est épris
depuis le début de cette crise en
nommant elisabeth bornes qui est
certainement une femme très aux
estimable et très compétente mais et qui
n'a pas la stature politique à prendre
les choses en main il n'a pas voulu
comme certains le lui conseiller nommé
quelqu'un qui avait un poids politique
comme bruno le maire
qui aurait pu être à la manoeuvre
pendant que lui se retirait sur son rôle
de président de la vème république
s'occupant de l'international du
fonctionnement des institutions il n'a
pas voulu entendre ça résultat il se
retrouve dans un système où les poids
lourds politiques autour de lui sont des
gens comme gérald darmanin sébastien
lecornu bruno le maire qui au viennent
de la droite qui ont des agendas
politiques à eux alors que ce qui était
vraiment très proche de lui sans
arrière-pensée jean yves le drian
richard ferrand christophe castaner ne
sont plus là donc il est seul il s'en
plaint d'ailleurs même s'il a beaucoup
contribué à sa solitude mais perdent
plusieurs de ses proches disent qu'il se
plaint d'être d'être seul et je ne vois
pas comment il peut avoir les moyens
d'inventer cette nouvelle méthode à ce
stade je n'en vois pas le chemin
plus du bilan mais non on peut plaider
aussi pour rien' pour animer
la réflexion mais parce que là vous êtes
un peu tout ça non mais on peut plaider
d'anciens s'avère d'abord il a fait
preuve d'un pragmatisme et oui contraire
à ses propres convictions sur le quoi
qu'il en coûte par exemple ils étaient
quand même venus 1 pour restreindre les
déficits etc et en deux temps trois
mouvements il a fait demi tour donc il
peut faire
encore que les hauts fonctionnaires de
bercy se poser au gramme de françois
fillon lui voulait redresser les
finances exactement mais il peut on peut
penser qu'ils peuvent faire demi-tour là
aussi après avoir méprisé les corps
intermédiaires pendant des mois et des
mois et de façon mais absolument
incroyable on peut imaginer que sous la
pression de l'opinion qui est quand même
de manière écrasante 1 pour réinventer
le dire pour limiter ses pouvoirs et
pour que on réinvente eu une forte des
changes on peut penser qu'il pourrait
changer de comportement et troisième
point ce qui pourrait nous amener à
penser ça aussi nous conduire à penser
ça
quand il était ministre de l'économie
qu'il a pondu sa loi à venir il a passé
des semaines à l'assemblée nationale
retournez à la fourchette à escargots
les députés les uns après les autres doc
il a quand même en souvenir dans
l'ariège occiput très loin mais ça peut
revenir en avant son jeu dépend aussi du
jeu des autres vieux il est illettré
s'isoler du jeu des autres c'est ça
aussi la prof surtout il n'est pas le
président enfin le chef de la majorité
parlementaire c'est le premier ministre
et le chef de la majorité parlementaire
le présent de la république la majorité
présidentielle ça n'est pas la même
chose ou sinon il a été désavoué aux
législatives mais c'est ça la limite
parce que il ya le fait mais je suis
assez d'accord avec vous ça dépend des
autres et les français où la classe
politique est drogué au fait majoritaire
mais peut-être aussi drogué une espèce
de gouvernance ultracentralisée ultra
verticale parce qu'il ya toute la partie
immergée de l'iceberg parce que le tout
n'est pas de se montrer constructive de
bonne volonté ou je sais pas quel
qualificatif avenant en a derrière il ya
le fait de choisir tous les directeurs
de cabinet des ministres de choisir
parfois les membres de leurs cabinets de
se substituer finalement au gouvernement
de se substituer aux corps
intermédiaires de se substituer dans un
certain nombre de circonstances au
parlement lui même et cette culture là
emmanuel macron qu'il a inventé un jet à
se demander s'il n'était pas déjà là ça
n'est pas l'inventer mais il a
probablement poussé plus loin encore que
d'autres alors peut-être à cause des
crises que nous avons vécu mais aussi
probablement à cause d'une part de
personnalités regarder ce que gérard
collomb qui le connaît bien il était un
des premiers à la compagnie andy dont il
dit encore dans l'interview qui donnait
me sens utile dans le point là pendant
cette campagne présidentielle en disant
que finalement il alterne entre la
pensée et cosmique
ce qui de manière déjà samedi claire de
formuler des choses il n'y pas une
pensée macroéconomiques ou une vision on
dit la pensée cosmin bain et le micro
management mais c'est vrai que madame
macro nous a quand même fait avaler le
fait qu'il ne faisait pas campagne parce
qu'il était occupé par la guerre en
ukraine ça n'a pas empêché de regarder
circonscription par circonscription qui
était investi par les candidats ensemble
vous voyez bien que cette tendance au
micro management aussi elle participe à
l'entrée en résonance avec cette espèce
gouvernance ultra simple et ça pose la
question de son attitude dans l'est dans
les jours et les semaines à venir
vis-à-vis de l'assemblée a semblé sans
majorité absolue qui oblige emmanuel
macron peut-être peut-être à changer en
tout cas c'est ce que disait la
présidente du groupe elle est fille
mathilde de panneaux en l'écoutent
n'en déplaise à monsieur macron c'est
que justement il n'est plus le seul à
décider mais que maintenant l'assemblée
nationale n'est plus sa chambre
d'enregistrement ni son paillasson et
qu'il va donc faire avec une assemblée
nationale qui est fort et on en faire la
démonstration et steve jours d'un rebond
soir steve
on se penchera grâce à vous sur le cette
semaine politique très chargé qui qui
débute même macro on va forcément suivre
de très près le calendrier l'assemblée
oui ça commence dès demain avec
l'élection au perchoir le poste très
délicat est très stratégique de
président de l'assemblée sera attribué
ce mardi à partir de 15h à quoi ça sert
un président d'assemblée bien ça sert à
présider les séances évidemment dans la
mystique mais aussi à jouer les
médiateurs entre majorité et opposition
autant dire qu'il y aura beaucoup
beaucoup de boulot dans les mois qui
viennent trois candidats sont
officiellement en lice ya annie genevard
pour les lr sébastien chenu pour le
rassemblement national il ya lebron
privé pour la coalition présidentielle
et puis ils devraient aussi avoir un
candidat de gauche pour les départager
les députés vont devoir voter ici aucun
de ces candidats ne remporte la majorité
des suffrages il y aura un troisième
tour 3e tour qui se jouera à la majorité
relative sauf surprise il ya elle brûle
privés devraient rafler la mise ce
serait la première fois dans l'histoire
qu'une femme est élue à ce poste à
suivre demain également thomas la
constitution des groupes politiques
chaque groupe doit remettre la liste
définitive de ses membres il devra aussi
de dire eh bien s'il se considère comme
étant dans la majorité ou dans
l'opposition c'est donc une échéance
importante qui emmanuel macron va
regarder avec beaucoup beaucoup
d'attention sera demain quel est le
rapport de force à l'assemblée nationale
pour les cinq années qui viennent depuis
fin de suspense cette semaine aussi pour
la très convoitée présidence de la
commission des finances oui préparez le
popcorn journée capitale jeudi puisque
les 577 députés vont intégrer l'une des
huit commissions permanentes du palais
bourbon c'est dans ces commissions qu'on
prépare et qu'on débat des textes de loi
avant qu'ils arrivent dans l'hémicycle
politiquement le combats se concentrent
autour de la prestigieuse commission des
finances dont on me parle présidence
kippour
président de cette institution qui
permet d'agir comme un contre-pouvoir en
fait à la politique économique du
gouvernement alors qui pour la présider
les positions les oppositions la
revendique un vote aura lieu à bulletins
secrets pour le rassemblement national
premier groupe d'opposition le candidat
et le député de la somme jean philippe
tanguy pour la nuque le candidat devrait
être le député de seine-saint-denis eric
coquerel et au milieu de ça et bien les
députés aient l'air devraient jouer les
arbitres puisque elisabeth borrel a
confirmé la coalition présidentielle ne
prendra pas part au vote c'est donc à la
droite de dire ce qu'elle préfère entre
une présidence lepénistes et une
présidence mélenchonistes ça va être
intéressant de suivre sa difficile de
savoir ce qui est manuel ma contraire en
l'occurrence merci steve pour toutes ces
informations
nicolas domenach s'il faut inventer des
majorités au cas par cas parce que c'est
sans doute ce qui pourrait se passer
dans l'est dans les prochaines semaines
est-ce que emmanuel macron là je parle
encore de psychologie de où d'habitude
est-ce qu'il va forcément mettre les
mains dans le cambouis un peu comme
jean-sébastien nous le disait pour
désigner les têtes de liste pour les
législatives
il peut pas ne pas le faire oui c'est
danser dans nos habitudes d'abord et
puis c'est dans la structure même de
cette majorité là je veux dire elle
reste ma chronique ailleurs même s'il
essuie un échec aux législatives il
reste celui qui les a portés à la
victoire avec la difficulté qui sera pas
celui de la prochaine bataille pour la
présidentielle donc ça rendra les choses
plus difficiles mais je pense que encore
une fois ce qui va être déterminant
c'est moins macron encore que il va s'en
servir beaucoup c'est comment ils sont
cependant l'opinion publique intervient
là dessus parce que personne ne souligne
assez à mon avis de le fait qu'une
majorité aussi massive 10 entendez-vous
nom d'un chien ça suffit de vous
affronter comme ça là on a
un conflit avec les partis politiques
qui eux défendent leur bout de gras leur
boutique danse intérêts de boutique qui
sont réels qu'ils peuvent comprendre
mais vous avez à côté de ça et le
premier vous souvenez pendant la
cohabitation balladur ailleurs on disait
le premier qui tire aura perdu le
premier qui dégainera aura perdu mon
avis le premier qui va vraiment faire la
faute de s'opposer à une volonté une loi
populaire et de manière trop flagrante
il va le payer très cher
est ce que c'est le l'analyse du vote
forcément ça non je crois pas il ya 70%
des français qui sont contents qu'il n'y
ait pas de majorité des séries sont
contents qui n'est pas de majorité pour
une manade macron ils n'ont pas souhaité
non plus en conflit à d'autres et pas
particulièrement parce qu'ils attendent
des espèces des alliances improbables
les français sont pas dupes sur la
culture politique qui est celle de notre
pays ni probablement sur les
institutions je pense qu'ils les
comprennent d'ailleurs mieux kamal el ma
conséquent emmanuel macron par d'espagne
d'italie il feint d'oublier ou alors
c'est inquiétant s'il oublie totalement
que le chancelier ou le président du
conseil italien sinum matteo salvini mr
l'intérieur il lui délègue vraiment le
ministère de l'intérieur il n'est encore
une fois choisi pas son directeur de
cabinet il ne se substitue pas à la
politique mise en oeuvre il ya un accord
global qui se passe regarder ce qui se
passe là en allemagne c'est le fdp le
parti libéral qui est au ministère des
finances c'est la vision du fdp sur les
finances publiques allemandes qui
l'emportent ce n'est pas celle du spd et
pourtant c'est le spd qui est le premier
groupe en nombre de sièges
à la chance enfin windows tag pardon en
allemagne et donc on est dans cette
espèce de confusion qui fait que ans à
mon avis d'ailleurs les manades macron
s'impliquant trop en se substituant à
celui ou celle qui doit être le chef de
la majorité parlementaire se met en
danger parce que defacto imaginer qu'ils
deviennent à dissoudre l'assemblée ou
alors que d'ailleurs jamais le rapport
de force politique ne se reconstitue il
sera beaucoup plus loin des légitimité
de son élection présidentielle et il se
mettra dans le rôle de celui qui pour le
coup pourrait réellement être désavoué
par corinne lhaïk si on reparle des
investisseurs et législatif c'est
intéressant parce que ça peut éclairer
un autre trait de la personnalité des
mails macro la difficulté à il a du mal
à séparer des gens on peut dire ça comme
ça oui il a du mal à se séparer des
champs c'est vrai il y cam et même ceux
avec lesquels il a eu un conflit il
laisse mijoter pendant un certain temps
et après ils cherchent toujours à se
rapprocher d'eux et à se rabibocher donc
là il y avait des députés sortants l'une
disait franchement oui
absolument et il a voulu il ya beaucoup
il a insisté quand même l'ouïe mais
finalement ils n'aiment pas les n'aime
pas les conflits n'aime pas les
séparations il n'aime pas les ruptures
et si je devais parler de la rupture
essentiel que beaucoup appellent de
leurs voeux en ce moment celle avec
alexis colère je ne pense pas qu'il est
sur la voie de la menace alexis colère
dont on dit beaucoup de mal à une grande
caractéristique c'est qu'il est
parfaitement c'est pas deux jumeaux de
macron c'est sa doublure et c'est
surtout son complément il sans boîte
parfaitement avec lui il compense ses
défauts il le connaît très bien emmanuel
macron sous ses allures de technocrates
inspecteur des finances et banquiers
d'affaires est quelqu'un qui a un
tempérament un peu d'artistes un peu de
saltimbanques et parfois il lui arrive
de s'envoler dans le lyrisme avec des
idées pas tout à fait opérationnel et
alexis colère et l'homme qui vient
canaliser tout ça alors parfois trop
pour ceux qui veulent avoir un peu plus
de disruption et de créativité mais
c'est vrai que colère et l'homme qui
fait rentrer l'édredon dans l'analyse
la rupture ni le pardon est ce qui est
arrivé à guillaume larrivé qui pourtant
a donné moult gageure essayer de se
rapprocher de la majorité macron n'a pas
voulu en entendre parler parce que c'est
fini quand c'est fini de l'arrivée
s'était montré très dur sur jet sur la
question de du secrétaire général de la
présidence de la république habib sy
colère nicolas domenach est-ce que
emmanuel macron peut changer sans
changer générale je trouve impossible je
trouve c'est un des drames de ce
quinquennat précédent et de celui ci
c'est que vous ne pouvez pas impunément
avec quelqu'un d'aussi important pendant
huit ans veut dire c'est effectivement
son double may qui travail de 7 heures
du matin deux heures du matin quasiment
je dire c'est à dire que c'est quelqu'un
qui est complètement coupée de tout le
reste il n'a plus de vie il ya l'idée
n'a que sa vie avec emmanuel macron qui
lui arrive de temps en temps de se
bouger pour manger un centre
méditer surréaliste vous en connaissez
rien c'est l'absence d'enrichissement
qu' il s' est arrivé blessé par
des qualités il est formidablement
intelligents il a traduit tic mais il
n'est pas politique
oui ils privilégient les solutions
techniques il est par exemple persuadé
et ce dès depuis le mois d'avril 2021
alors que emmanuel macron avait remisé
sa réforme des retraites avec l'âge
pivot à 64 ans que les français veulent
travailler plus que les français ont
compris la nécessité de travailler plus
et veulent travailler plus et c'est lui
qui a effectivement poussé pour la
retraite à 65 ans et sa part d'un des
sentiments et d'une analyse tout à fait
honorable et respectable et certainement
juste mais je pense qu'il n'y a pas la
prise en compte de l'acceptabilité
sociale d'une telle d'une telle mesure
il est malsain raisonnement qui est un
peu biaisé sous la réalité pourquoi 65
ans et pas du tout une réflexion qu'il y
ait au système des retraites en soit
c'est pour se donner de l'oxygène
budgétaire c'est parce que si vous
faites ça ça vous évite de réformes et
ailleurs et d'aller chercher des
économies ailleurs dans les finances
publiques c'est assez santé
c'est assez politique en réalité parce
que c'est l'illustration du manque de
courage peut-être parce que madame
macron a constaté pendant son premier
quinquennat elle écrit ce qu'il a
traversé qu'il n'y arriverait pas
justement réformer l'état français il ya
aussi quelque chose qui le meut cescom
une volonté d'imprimer sa marque dans
l'histoire donc est ce que ça sera
suffisant pour le faire changer ou pas
je n'en suis pas persuadé parce qu'il
est gamin naturel qu'est la r d'habitus
quelqu'un qui est bien est bien implanté
mais s'il ne veut pas être le président
dont le mandat a fini en quenouille et
dans un certain bazar
il ya aussi ça qui peut qui peut qu'ils
aient commencé avec la proposition de
loi sur les musées entend bien mais je
sais dans d'enfin se fait de mieux mais
dans la ccico logis des macros et de
vouloir compter lors de sa conférence de
presse du 17 mars et 17 de choses que je
n'ai pas réussi à faire c'est la réforme
des retraites et celle des institutions
donc on voit bien que c'est quelque
chose qui lui tient à coeur notamment la
réforme des retraites qui est vraiment
très très mal parti pendant le premier
quinquennat qui avait un accord et que
s'ils ne s'étaient pas obstiné il y
avait un accord avec la cfdt c'est quand
même dingue à merveille c'est à dire
qu'on est à d'ailleurs fait le bilan il
faut dire que ces jeunes aient un impact
sur le pib français les semaines devant
la cage il est aux crises auto ans je
sais la crise de l'accueil
arrêté les compteurs et il est difficile
de savoir si condé sombre maladie que
l'ademe la caisse qui se préoccupent
déjà de l'héritage politique l'héritage
politique je ne parle pas de la trace
dans l'histoire mais l'héritage
politique qui pourra laisser derrière
lui qu'est ce qui restera du maquereau
et liste comptait manel macron sera la
fin de sa dépend dans quel sens où vous
l'entendez si vous l'entendez dans le
sens qu'il va passer le flambeau vous
savez bien que les politiques simpsons
qui ne supporte pas c'est ça parce que
c'est précipité leur mort donc ne
choisira pas un successeur mais je pense
qu'il est habité quand même par l'idée
il sait qu'il ya une malédiction du
deuxième mandat que tous les 2e mandat
set se termine soit en quenouille soit
fin ne laisse aucune eau il faut qu'il
laisse quand même comment l'évoquait une
une trace dans l'histoire pour l'instant
on ne la voit pas venir je dire mais il
faudra bien c'est pour ça je crois qu'il
va sans se rebeller de l'histoire en
cours à un moment ou un autre des riz
sera obligé d'être disruptif dans l'est
dans un an ou quelque chose de ce genre
là je pense qui n'a d'ailleurs qu'une
seule carte pour l'instant c'est celle
de bruno le maire à abattre veut dire
pour réinventer quelque chose parce que
lui lui peut gérer il peut gérer les
politiques il a une aussi il est habité
par une exigence politique au sens que
noble commandes évoqué tout à l'heure
je sais pas mais bon on fait avec ce
qu'on a
il nous reste une minute c'est un peu
c'est un peu court pour aborder un
dernier thème mais je voulais qu'on
parle quand même de la supposée mise du
président avec ce paradoxe est que je
pose ça alors qu'il va peut-être se
retrouver
entouré de trois femmes à des postes
clés la première mini sylla le brut pib
on en parle et qui pourrait devenir la
première femme président de l'assemblée
et puis aussi hors berger qui a été vu
la semaine dernière à la tête du groupe
renaissance il est misogyne donc pas non
pas du tout
oui c'est vrai parce que c'est son
parcours que c'est souvent le cas dans
les cabinets à très haut niveau les les
hommes souvent soit ne ne porte pas les
enfants soient ne les élèves pas soit
sont très jeunes et n'ont pas ce souci
là donc ça explique quand même la forte
présence d'hommes
il a tendance il respecte énormément les
femmes peut-être que il a une
je dirais qu'il n'a peut-être pas tout à
fait le mode d'emploi avec les femmes il
a peut-être une espèce de retenue par
exemple il est très tactile et il ne
l'est pas avec avec les familles fait
attention mais les femmes travaillent
avec lui ne disent pas sentir des bizots
j'ai dit franchement voilà on aura quand
même répondu à cette question merci vous
êtes à la paix merci à tous d'avoir
participé à ce débat très vite vos
livres la nuit tombe deux fois co écrit
avec eric m'en donner chez fayard et
puis macron pourquoi tant de haine
co écrit avec maurice szafran et publié
aux éditions albin michel voit la fin de
cette émission